well pride month helps us celebrate the
lgbtq plus Community but during a time
of Celebration some historic sites in
our nation are honoring the community
and they're now facing several incidents
of vandalism The Stonewall monument in
New York City name one 8 news now
Victoria Saha sat down with a Las Vegas
woman who was part of this important
time in history and reflects on the
difficulties those in these communities
continue to face
in the 1960s Judy Bowen was living in
New York City you had to live a life to
to exist very few knew she was a
transgender woman it was illegal in this
country for a transsexual to dress
according to their their reality but
those at the Stonewall Inn knew exactly
who she was Stonewall what did that mean
to you when you stepped in and you saw
that it was a place of acceptance oh
that was our harm because we weren't
accepted any other place that home as
Safe Haven but in the 1960s New York
City Police would raid bars searching
and arresting gay and trans people but
one night they fought back it's now
known as The Stonewall Uprising a
landmark movement for lgbtq plus rights
wait what do you remember about the
uprising it was going to happen because
there was so much abuse from the police
uh because basically we were illegal
decades later across the iconic bar sits
The Stonewall National Monument to
commemorate this change in history but
recently during this pride month several
Pride flags have been torn down a step
backwards says Bowen I thought we would
progress I thought our society would
would understand that people are people
since moving to Las Vegas in the 1990s
Bowen has made it a mission to be a
voice for the lgbtq plus Community to me
there's
there's only one race the human race
now the Stonewall Inn Bar in Greenwich
Village still open to the public New
York City Police have not made any
arrests regarding the recent vandalism